This video is made possible by brilliance.
You'll learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to know more about them right now, you can go to
brilliance.org/biographics. You'll also find a link in the description below
All the worlds are staged and all men and women merely players,
they have their exits and their entrances.
And one man in his time plays many parts.
William Shakespeare was the greatest writer of all time.
He has had the biggest impact on literature for all of human history.
Some historians even believe that he may have written the first English
translation of the king James Bible.
During his lifetime, he published 38 plays 154 sonnets in several poems.
His writing has been translated into every single language in the world,
making him one of the only writers who is universally popular with everyone.
So who was this man?
And how did his life experience shape him into someone so profound that his
words have lasted for hundreds of years?
Most historians believe that Shakespeare was born approximately April the 23rd,
1564 in Stratford upon AEN in Warwickshire, England. His father,
John Shakespeare was the son of successful farmers and glove maker.
John was very popular in town and made a lot of friends. One year.
He was given the hell hilarious position of Stratford's official ale taster.
And in 1568, he was appointed as the high bailiff,
which is like a modern day mayor. Aside from this glove business,
John also had a side hustle trading wool,
which was actually illegal to do without a proper license. During this time,
John bought several properties in Stratford and was moving up in both financial
and social status. However,
this upward mobility would come to a halt when John was finally caught for
illegally trading will, he was forced to go to court and pay substantial fines.
William Shakespeare only attended primary school to the age of 13 because his
father could no longer pay for the tuition after his legal scandal.
No one is sure what young William did between the ages of 13 to 18,
but he most likely worked with his father to help keep the family business
afloat. According to the records kept by the Shakespeare birthplace trust.
William was just 18 years old when he got a 26 year old woman named Anne
Hathaway pregnant in Elizabeth in England, the age of consent was 21.
So William had to get Anne's father's permission for the two of them to get
married. This would've been very shameful in the eyes of Elizabeth and society.
Normally parents helped to arrange marriages with their young daughters and
eligible suiters.
Women never had a choice in who they married in this courtship process.
It often started in their teenage years.
Girls could get married as young as 12 if their parents gave consent.
But the majority began searching for their daughters,
husbands the age of 14 or 15 with young men.
However, most parents allowed their sons to choose their own wife.
After the age of consent at 21, by age 26,
women were considered to be an old maid because they would've gone through over
10 years of courtship and had no proposals of marriage.
If a woman went too long without fighting her husband,
she was considered to have something seriously wrong with her and would be
labeled a witch and Hathaway was already 26 and failed to find a husband,
many historians speculates that Anne must have seduced the young ands,
naive William Shakespeare, knowing that it would force them to get married.
This held young Shakespeare back from pursuing his dream for year years back
then if a young man was already a father,
he was no longer eligible to become an apprentice in a skilled trade.
So getting a woman pregnant as a teenager would essentially sentence a man to a
life of poverty and he would be doomed to work in the lowest paying jobs for the
rest of his life. They were married in November of fifteen eighty two,
six months later, Dan gave birth to their due order. Susan, as a teenage parent,
Shakespeare did not have the money to care for a child.
And so he and Anne had to live with William's parents.
He had five younger siblings who were just two to 13 years old when their
daughter Susan was born.
There are no records that give us an insight into how William felt about Anne,
but the lack of evidence speaks volumes. Most writers can't help,
but gush with words of admiration about the people they love,
considering that he would create some of the most romantic stories of all time.
We know that he must have fallen in love at some point in his life,
but most historians believe that his inspiration came from affairs that he had
in later life.
William and Anne went on to have twins of boy and a girl named hams and Judith
between the years that his twin were born in 1585 and the points where he moved
to London to become a writer in 1592,
they've been called the lost years back then it was totally normal for people
not to keep records of their own lives,
especially when you were just your average laborer.
But this period of time has become legendary amongst Shakespeare nerds,
who like to imagine what sort of life would've led him to ultimately decide to
be move to London, to become an actor. Since there are no records,
everything that has been written about the lost years is basically fan fiction.
The only real clue is a poem from his play as you like it,
which has been called the seven ages of man.
This is people speculating that he may have become a soldier or a legal clerk.
However, this was written in a work of fiction.
So really may have nothing to do with his personal life. For now,
much of his young life will simply remain a mystery.
During the Elizabeth and era,
there was an economic expansion in England with more money comes more time for
leisure. So citizens were indulging in the art more than ever before.
Records of William Shakespeare.
Living in London as an actor began when he was 28 years old, his wife, Anne,
and his children,
they remains living in his father's home and Stratford upon AEN and he would
send money to support them. Before he wrote plays.
He had been publishing poetry and sonnets with the help of wealthy patrons at
the time becoming an actor was not the dream career that it is today. In fact,
actors were considered to be untrustworthy Vaga bonds who came from the lowest
class of society in this way,
because struggles in earlier life may have actually been a blessing in disguise
because if he had had a better job,
he may have never stooped so low as to run away and to join the theater.
He began working as an acting company called Lord Chamberlain's men for years,
Shakespeare mainly worked as an actor and would only occasionally submit a
script of a play or a sonnet for the company to perform after performing some of
its plays.
Coworkers realized that Shakespeare's scripts were by far the most popular,
and they drew the biggest crowds.
It made the most financial sense for the troop to continue performing
Shakespeare's work above anyone else's the troop would rent the stage from the
owner of the globe theater. At the time,
there were several popular theaters in London called the rose,
the hope and the Swan.
This meant they were far from being the only company who was trying to capture
an audience's attention.
The performers at the globe became so popular that the entire city would come to
see Shakespeare's work.
Theater was set up to incorporate special effects into their performances like
traps and overhead rigging.
At one point performances at the globe were so popular.
Even members of the Royal family would come to see them on a regular basis.
When king James, I first came to power,
he decided to sponsor Lord Chamberlain's men.
So they changed the company name to the King's man.
In the beginning of his playwriting career,
Shakespeare wrote biographies about the lives of king Henry II and Richard II
Shakespeare's plays were considered to be historically accurate for a long time.
However, after discovering the remains of Richard III,
scientists realized that Shakespeare had exaggerated his physical appearance.
So it's likely that he also exaggerated his personality. Now,
by the time he was 32 years old, Shakespeare came out with his first play.
There was a complete work of fiction called the comedy of errors that same year,
Ian 1596 William's father John Shakespeare was able to secure a family coat of
arms,
which was a sign that the family was now accepted into the upper echelons of
society.
In 1597, William Shakespeare was 33 years old and his writing career,
it was finally successful enough so that he could afford to buy his own house
for his wife and children in Stratford, upon a, he called the house new place.
At the time they would've taken two to three days of travel on horseback to get
to London. So he always kept an apartment in the city.
The stereotype that actors were Vons wasn't too far from the truth. Actually,
at the very least, you could say that they were incredibly crafty in 1597, the,
of the globe theater Gils Allen wanted to tear it down so they could sell the
land. He abruptly ended the lease with the Lord Chamberlain's men.
This would've ruined their careers since most other theaters in London were full
with their competitors. But someone came up with a genius solution.
They offered to give Gils Allen free labor to dismantle the theater themselves
in exchange for them putting the materials to better use Allen plan,
to just burn the wood anyway.
So he didn't see any problem with that.
The theater troop got together in the middle of the night,
carefully tear down the theater,
and they went to a property across the TAs river.
Then they used all of these free materials to rebuild the globe theater.
Exactly. As it had been only now it was across the river.
They had the exact same performance space without having to pay their rent.
This stunt became the talk of the town and only made their company even more
popular. But the landlord, he was furious.
Charles Allen tried to take them to court,
to Sue them for the value of the theater. After reading the contract, he signs,
the judge found the Lord Chamberlain's men not guilty of any crime as they had
every right to do whatever they wanted with the materials for the rest of his
life. William Shakespeare's reputation would continue to grow.
And he was nothing short of a celebrity. Now,
just before we get into the rest of that life,
let me tell you a bit about today's sponsor brilliance.
Brilliance are a science learning platform that allow you to learn through
active learning.
This sums up is basically the opposite of that field of,
of reading a super complex paragraph about some principle and then having
absolutely no clue what it's about, even on the 10th read through.
So I've mentioned brilliant before.
You probably know that if you watch this channel regularly,
and I think it's a great fit because here you are watching a 20 minute
educational video on YouTube.
You're probably into learning and brilliant a great at enabling that brilliant.
Also have things called daily challenges, which are just five minutes,
which allow you to read a short paragraph, answer a question,
then learn about a new concept.
It's a really great way. If you're busy like me,
maybe you don't have time to dive into like a full course about something,
but you can just grab one of those daily challenges and make it a part of your
daily routine. Also brilliant can now be accessed offline.
So if you're in somewhere with spot internet,
or you don't want to use your data,
you can just have the brilliant app on your phone.
You can access those daily challenges or other stuff from their app on the phone
without having to use any data. All brilliance courses are totally interactive.
So you can learn probability by playing a game of blackjack or learn the
physics, emotion using interactive models of pendulum clocks,
that kind of stuff. So if you are of the support biographics,
which is cool of you, and to get unlimited access to all of brilliance in depth,
math and maths and science courses, you can head over to
brilliant.org/biographics to get 20% off their annual premium subscription.
And let's get back to Shakespeare.
Now that William Shakespeare was living on his own and succeeded in his career,
he was able to enjoy the freedoms of being a bachelor.
There is some speculation that he may have actually been bisexual after all
plays during near Elizabeth Niro, always performed with an all male cast.
Then with fair features would cross dress to play the female roles.
And they would often kiss on stage.
This is one of the many reasons why actors were considered to be so low class as
well for a man who choose to leave his wife and kids and run away to the
theater.
It's not so hard to imagine that his sexuality may have had something to do with
it. One of the biggest pieces of evidence is his sonnet fair youth,
which holds the famous line. Shall I compare the, to a summer's day?
It is very romantic,
but few people realize that it was a actually a love poem written about a young
man.
He kept that poem hidden for years, until it was recovered after his death,
it was later edited to remove all of the male pronouns,
but there is one line where he describes the fair youth as having a woman's
face.
One of the leading theories is the identity of the fair youth is one of his
first patrons, Henry Ryther Lee, the third Earl of, of Hampton.
He began to financially support Shakespeare's work at the beginning of his
writing career.
And they remained loyal friends long after he became a famous playwright,
looking at the portraits of young Henry, he truly does look androgynous,
and he seems to be the most likely candidate for the historians who feel
threatened by the idea that Shakespeare was not straight.
They try to claim that they were really just good friends because you know,
it's totally normal for dudes to write love poems about each other. Right? Um,
yeah. Another poem may have revealed details of one of Shakespeare's lovers.
This time in Sonic called the dark lady where he describes woman with black hair
and eyes with brown skin,
historians have tried to figure out who this woman was.
There are several theories,
including that he was writing about a famous London sex worker,
nicknamed black loose.
We do not know how much time he spent in Stratford upon a, with his family,
but considering how busy he was working in London,
most speculates that he only saw them on holidays.
When William Shakespeare was in his 40,
his son Hamlet died at just 11 years old at the time the bubonic plague was
killing people across England.
And one third of the children died by the age of 10.
Hamnet had been his only son. So his death affected him. Deeply.
Many people speculate that the death of his son is what inspired him to write
his play Hamlet.
For years, some historians have speculated.
The William Shakespeare may not have worked alone because they have a hard time
believing that someone who stopped his education by the age of 13 could grow up
to be the greatest writer of all time.
We do know that a fellow play writer named Thomas Middleton,
either collaborated or edited Shakespeare's work.
It's perfectly normal for writers to collaborate on project together.
And he probably got plenty of feedback from his coworkers in the acting troop.
However,
most modern day readers will never even see just how impressive his writing
truly was. And a trained eye can see the progression in his style.
The way we pronounce words in the English language is dramatically changed in
his original scripts.
There is even more rhyming and clever puns hidden in the dialogue that a modern
day reader ever pick up on. And yet it's still incredible.
Even if we miss half of the jokes at the very beginning of this video,
we mentioned that he may have had a hands in collaborating with the king James
Bible in 16, 10 king James set out to translate the Bible from Latin to English.
But for those who have studied theology,
you already know that the translation is not exact William Shakespeare was one
of the most suspected writers in England at the time and king James would've
surely gone to see his plays.
So it would only make sense that he may have been at least one of the
collaborators on writing the Bible.
William Shakespeare was 46 years old at the time.
And the project began soon after his birthday historians with way too much time
on the hands figured out that Tom 46,
if you count out 46 words from the inning of the verse,
you'll find the word shake.
And then if you count 46 words backwards from the ends,
you'll find the word spear most believe that this is enough evidence to prove
that he really did write the book and that this was the only way he could slip
his authorship into the text. Even though we see as hidden signature,
we still do not know if he wrote to the entirety of the king James Bible by
himself, or if there were other collaborators, however,
you can take a quotation quiz online called Bible or Shakespeare.
You'll quickly realize that the writing styles between Shakespeare's plays and
the Bible are so similar that even fans have trouble knowing the difference.
Now, there is a common saying that Shakespeare was so profound that every single
story risen since then cannot help but be influenced by him or the Bible.
And since he wrote both, it's all really just him.
In 16, 13,
the globe theater burns to the grounds during a performance of Henry the eighth,
they were shooting off cannons to create a realistic effect of battle,
but they accidentally set fire to the theater. After the fire,
he stopped writing because there was nowhere for his place to be performed.
The troop began to rebuild the theater almost immediately,
but for William Shakespeare,
this situation was so traumatic that he needed a break from writing.
He moved back to live with Anne Hathaway and strapped upon AEN and died just
three years later in 2018, a movie called all his true speculated.
What life must have been like for him during his short retirements,
historians have noted that in these last three years,
William Shakespeare's handwriting was very shaky from hand tremors.
This could have indicated that he had contracted syphilis from one of his lovers
and was now in the latest stages of the disease.
Some believe that he was also offering from mercury poisoning,
and this may explain some of his more darkened tragic work in 16, 16,
William Shakespeare was 52 years old. And on the verge of death,
he wrote his last will testaments,
which is where we find the only time he had ever written about his wife.
It said, I, I give on to my wife are the second best bed. And the furniture,
many husbands made their wives executors of their will and wrote some romantic
words about how they trusted them with their estates. But no,
that's all Shakespeare had to say after he died,
the men who worked together with William Shakespeare in the King's men gathered
together his scripts to preserve them for future generations.
This is known as the first fol later,
the poetry that we attributed to him was added to the second fol and whatever
they could find was considered his complete works. But of course,
there's always a chance that he had written other pieces that the world never
knew about. Even though these plays were kept by a ragtag group factors,
his words resonated with people so much that it became a worldwide phenomenon.
So what makes Shakespeares writing so good?
How is it lasted for hundreds of years?
And people are still reading it today and being inspired by it.
The answer is that Shakespeare took the time to study human beings no matter who
we are.
All people share common emotions and life experiences in fiction characters
often get placed in scenarios where it's easy to find solutions.
The night stays the dragon. The princess is real rescued by a prince,
most legendary stories and fairy tales. They're black and white,
but Shakespeare characters are truly complex.
Just like real people in real life.
We're sometimes put in a situation that is so difficult.
There is absolutely no right thing to do.
We simply have to follow our intuition and make a choice and then deal with any
negative consequences either way by Tapp into the human condition,
his tragedies, they were heart-wrenching and his romances were epic,
but through it all,
he tries to insert comedy to help people laugh at even the hardest things in
life.
His characters have helped people have more empathy for the plight of others
instead of casting judgment, farty quickly,
and every new generation of aspiring writers. Since then,
they've tried to accomplish the same.
We do not have any journals to figure out what went through William
Shakespeare's mind at the end of his life when he was struggling with a terminal
illness.
But we do have some very powerful insights into his mind from one of his last
place called the Tempest. He probably knew that he would die soon.
So within the text of this play,
he just may have tried to tell some of the most valuable advice that he learned
throughout his lifetime.
The main character is a man named prosper who was trapped on an island with his
daughter. He becomes a so,
and he communes with spirits who give him control over the weather at a certain
point in the story,
prosper seems to be on the brink of Manness says he uses his power to go after
his revenge, but throughout the course of the play,
he learns how to forgive his enemies,
not to judge people based on their appearances and to embrace love as being one
of the most powerful things in the world in the ends prosper asks the audience
for forgiveness, for the terrible things that he has done.
And this was met with thunders applause with this in mind.
What leave you with some of the last lines that William Shakespeare wrote in the
Tempest? Our revels now are ended. These are actors,
as I four told you we're all spirits and are melted into air.
We are such stuff as dreams are made on and our little life is rounded with a
sleep. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up bottom below,
and don't forget to subscribe brand new videos four times a week and hit that
notification bell.
So you find out when those actually come out and as always thank you for
watching.